"Then as I turned back to my work, I noticed
something in the corner of my eye.
Something was standing in my room now."
Hello, and welcome to Al Dente Creepypasta,
horror stories cooked to perfection with a
splash of red sauce.
My name is CZ and I will be your server this
episode.
Today's stories are perfect for a cozy night
of studying, relaxing and getting the chills
running down your spine at the absolute horror
that's about to unfold.
Make sure you get comfortable, and let's dig
right in.
---
Listening to music has always been my favorite
part of winding down when I get home every
evening.
Lately, I have really taken a liking to relaxing
in my room and jamming to some lo-fi chill
music.
Every night before I go to bed, I'll toss
on a YouTube stream, kick back and talk to
strangers in the chat for a bit before logging
out for the night.
I always find it interesting how this seems
to be the only internet chat section in the
known universe where people always get along,
and I feel like the chill music vibe has to
have something to do with it.
Lately I've started to notice that the same
group of people who tend to go online every
day around the same time.
Would it be too weird to call them my friends?
Even though we haven't met?
We all have similar interests, and it feels
like we can talk about anything: Cowboy Bebop,
old school video games, our favorite YouTubers
and even or burning hatred for our respective
English teachers.
I was chatting on the stream at our usual
time when a channel popped into the conversation
and wrote the words: ROLL CALL in all caps.
Random people started writing their location
in the chat: Chicago, Los Angeles, Tokyo.
Figuring there was no harm in simply putting
a city, I typed my mine into the chat and
continued to read where some of the others
were from.
That's when I started noticing that quite
a few of my 'friends' were close by.
Really close by.
I kind of daydreamed about what it would be
like if we met in real life, and as if to
read my mind, one of the regulars in the chat,
"ShadowHand1133" pointed out that we were
all actually really close to each other.
One thing led to another, and I know this
was a stupid idea, but we decided to meet
up.
I justified it in my head by telling myself
that we had all spoken to each other almost
every night on the chat.
It's not like anyone appeared out of the blue
and asked us to meet.
It felt safe.
And they felt like friends.
I’ll just say this right now, because I’m
sure you think you know where this is going.
Trusting the people I was talking to online
was not necessarily where I went wrong in
this story.
Actually, it may have been my saving grace
-- but there was one other thing I overlooked
-- that led to what I can only describe as
the scariest encounter of my life.
After school, I rode my bike to the 7/11 we
all decided to meet at around the edge of
town.
I got there a few minutes early and sat on
the curb to wait for the others.
I had no faces to look out for.
We only actually knew each other by username,
so everyone I saw walking in and out of the
convenience store was potentially one of us,
and I was imagining each new face I saw linking
up with a name.
But over the course of the next 20 minutes
nobody approached me, and I didn’t see any
messages from the others, even though I tried
hitting them up to see where they were at.
I was beginning to think that I was the only
one who showed when I heard a voice behind
me.
“Hey.”
I turned to see a man -- probably in his late
20s or early 30s, for some reason I specifically
remember his figure shading my eyes and blocking
the now setting sun.
“Are you part of the lo-fi group?”
I told him yes, and let him know both my YouTube
username and my real name.
He told me he was “shadowhand”, which
I instantly recognized as the one who had
the idea for the meetup in the first place.
I did notice that he didn’t mention his
real name, which was only a slightly weird
because I had given him my first name.
But understanding the somewhat awkward nature
of meeting people from online, I didn’t
press on the issue, since I didn’t want
to ask anything that might have made him uncomfortable.
I had also expected someone around the same
age as me, so seeing that he was significantly
older was also just a bit off-putting.
He told me that the rest of the group was
already hanging out down the street at one
of girls’ houses, and that he’d give me
a lift over there.
His car was parked on the side of the 7/11,
and after locking my bike up to a fence, I
followed him over towards it.
I’m fully aware of the dangers of getting
into a stranger’s car, so let me just clarify
what was going through my head at the moment.
The first thing that came out of his mouth
when he approached me was about the lo-fi
group.
So it’s not like I was just getting picked
up by some rando.
There were also several of us meeting up.
So unless this guy made a bunch of YouTube
accounts just to trick me into getting in
his car…
I felt like there wasn’t much of a threat.
He opened the back door of his SUV.
*ping*
I received a message from one of the group
members.
It was from him.
From ShadowHand1133.
It said he was in front of the 7/11 and he
was asking if anyone was here.
I froze in front of the open car door.
I looked up at the guy, then back down at
my phone.
“Did you send this?”
He said, yes, and tried to usher me into the
car, but then for the first time that afternoon,
something did NOT feel right.
I turned back and looked at the front of the
store, where I had been waiting before.
There was a kid standing there, about my age,
looking at a phone.
What happened next, is still talked about
to this day.
The kid turned around, and by some stroke
of luck spotted me and waved.
I turned and waved back, but before I could
tell the man who had offered me a ride that
there was someone back by the door of the
convenience store, I heard the car door SLAM
shut behind me.
The guy literally ran to the driver’s side,
and before I even knew what had happened,
he was in the car, turning the ignition and
flooring it out of the parking lot, before
booking it down the road like something out
of a bank robbery scene.
If you haven’t figured it out yet, I’ll
break it down for you.
The kid in front of the 7/11 was the real
ShadowHand1133.
The man in the car was just pretending to
be him since it was a recognizable name from
the chat.
We would later figure out that the man with
the car wasn’t anyone from the group who
had agreed to meet up -- but because we had
planned our get together on a public live
stream, anyone could see it.
That was our big mistake.
Even though all of us were trustworthy, some
random creep noticed our conversation and
decided to take advantage of it.
Police would later review the 7/11 security
footage to see the man pull up several minutes
before I arrived, hiding his SUV along the
side of the building, which was not covered
by any camera.
He must have waited there and scoped things
out through his dark tinted windows, then
upon realizing I was the only one who had
showed up, decided to make his move.
His license plate was never visible on camera
due to the angle at which he drove in.
While we do know he was one of the people
tuned into the livestream that day, the police
had no way of getting an actual list of IP
addresses or accounts who accessed it, soooo….
to this day, he has never been caught.
I guess there is one good thing that came
out of all of this though, outside of me really
putting my guard up.
The real ShadowHand and I because very good
friends, and it’s always an interesting
story when people ask how we know each other.
And no… that isn’t his real username,
I changed it for this story because you can
never be too careful.
He and I have spent many hours talking about
what might have happened to me if he had gotten
there a second later, and I had gotten into
that car.
It sends shivers down my spine thinking about
what that guy was planning to do or where
he was planning to take me in that dark-windowed
SUV of his…
I mean, what kind of kidnapper goes after
random people in a YouTube stream anyway?
He had no way of knowing who I was, or even
that I would show up to the meet up.
Let alone the fact that I was there by myself.
That’s the other thing.
We later found out that the other kids we
were supposed to meet up with just didn’t
show up, and decided not to let the group
know they’d no longer be coming.
I can’t say I blame them for bailing, considering
what almost happened, but it would have been
nice if they’d given a heads up.
As far as the lo-fi streams go, yeah, I still
listen to them and partake in the chat too.
It’s not like I’d be in any kind of danger
just because some freak knows my first name
and my face.
But there is something that still bothers
me through this entire experience.
Every time I write a message in the chat of
that stream… before I press enter, I think
about the possibility, that that guy with
the SUV is watching, and reading every message
that I put out...
--
*lo-fi song with sound effects*
I was planning on having my girlfriend over
later that evening, so I threw on some music
and got to cleaning the place.
I went upstairs to get started on my room,
since I figured we’d be spending the most
time there.
As I was making my bed, I heard what sounded
like someone rummaging around downstairs.
I do leave the door unlocked when she’s
coming over, but she wasn’t supposed to
come by for another hour and a half, and early
is not part of her vocabulary.
It took me a few moments to realize that the
song I was listening to sampling sound bites.
What I thought I heard was all a part of the
music.
I finished making my bed and started folding
some of the piles of clothes that covered
the majority of my bedroom floor.
*lo-fi music with sound effects*
No, no that sound had to be coming from downstairs.
I paused the music and listened closely.
*roomtone*
OK, maybe I was right the first time.
Maybe it was just part of the music.
I unpaused and sure, enough, the sound that
I thought I had heard was looping in the song.
I got back to work folding my clothes.
*lo-fi* *thud*
OK, that was definitely not part of the song.
I paused the music yet again, and just as
it paused, I heard a door close down below.
I called out my girlfriend’s name, to try
to put an end to whatever prank she was pulling
down there.
My heart stopped when I saw the scene at the
bottom of the stairs.
Every single closet, cupboard and drawer was
open, and the contents of each were thrown
on the ground.
My place had been ransacked!
The strange part was, nothing had been taken,
as far as I could tell.
Whoever was in my house, was looking for one
thing in particular, and I had no idea what
it was.
I did a brief search of the ground floor of
my house, but didn’t manage to turn anybody
up, so I took a seat on the stairs and dialed
9-1-1.
That’s when I heard noise coming from upstairs
behind me.
“Who’s there?”
Whoever had broken into my house had inadvertently
started playing my music again.
Or maybe it was on purpose.
I honestly had no idea at this point.
“Hello? 9-1-1, what’s your emergency.”
I had nearly forgotten that I was on the phone.
“I… uhm… there’s someone in my house.”
“Are you in a safe place where you can talk?”
...
I explained the situation, and they recommended
I get to a safe place such as a neighbor’s
house while they sent someone out.
I might have been inclined to stay and protect
my belongings, however, the intruder made
it quite clear he didn’t really care about
valuables, so for the better of my safety
I took their advice.
The intruder was never found, and nothing
was taken from my house as far as I could
tell.
I don’t leave the door open for my girlfriend
anymore, I made sure to copy her a key after
that night.
It’s also made me a bit paranoid whenever
I listen to music.
I’m constantly pausing if I hear anything
that doesn’t sound instrumental…
*pause music*
And if I even think I heard something…
I’m sure to check all around the house...
--
I take a night class on Wednesday evenings
at my university.
Usually I take an Ubar home, but I was running
a bit low on money and I decided to walk.
I typically listen to music when I walk.
Hoodie up and earbuds in.
When you have long hair like I do, you gotta
keep it dry.
There was a super light rainpour that night,
not even enough to use an umbrella, just enough
to where it felt like a nice cool mist with
my hood up.
So I was just casually walking home, looking
at the ground, not really paying much attention
to my surroundings.
I play this little game in my head where I
try to step on each sidewalk tile the same
amount of times.
So if I do it, I have like a perfectly paced
walk or something.
If you don’t get it, I probably can’t
explain it.
Anyway, I was looking down, and all the sudden,
I nearly step in this huge open manhole in
the ground.
I jump back and my heart’s beating out of
my chest, because I nearly just fell down
and broke my freaking neck at the bottom of
the sewers.
Who left this sewage cap open to begin with?
Naturally, I had to look down it.
It’s not every day you get to see an open
manhole.
I turned on my phone’s flashlight and peered
down inside.
What I didn’t expect to see was a pair of
eyes staring back up at me.
These eyes squinted as if they hadn’t seen
light in days, but that wasn’t the most
disturbing part.
This guy’s head was shaved, except for a
maybe a three inch diameter where the hair
was grown out about 12 inches or so.
So the result, was he was bald except for
this one messy tube of hair coming out of
the side of his head.
He wore a dirty beige jacket, and matching
jeans.
He also had huge dark bags underneath his
eyes.
And he immediately cowered away from the light
and hid in one of the pipes down below.
Not expecting to see someone down there, my
heart skipped a beat and I pulled away from
the rim of the manhole.
Who was that?
No… what was that?
Maybe I was just overreacting.
So there’s a homeless guy who takes shelter
in the sewers.
He probably came up because of all the rain
we’ve been getting, and got a little spooked
when I saw him.
As for his haircut?
Hard to explain that one.
But he’s living in the sewers.
He probably had some issues to begin with.
That’s just the sad truth of the matter.
I got home.
Took my shoes off under the awning.
Tossed my hoodie in the dryer.
It had gotten more damp than I thought over
the course of the long walk home.
I went on the computer for a bit before going
to bed.
That’s when I passed out.
*text message tone*
Until I realized my ringtone was still on.
I went to turn it off.
I had no interest in replying the message,
until I just happened to notice what it said
in the preview panel.
It was from my friend, who lived in the dorms
across the way from me.
It said, “who’s that by your window?”
What?
What was he talking about?
I reached over for the lightswitch.
*flips switch*
There was nothing at my window from what I
could tell.
At least… that’s what I thought at first…
and I do wish that was the case.
My window is one of those with a really strong
glare.
During the day, you can see out from the inside,
but if you try looking in from the outside,
it’s almost like looking in a mirror.
But during the night, it’s reversed, to
where it’s hard to see out from the inside,
but outsiders can see me provided that the
light is on and the blinds are up, which they
were.
Although looking out was kind of like looking
through a mirror, there was an unmistakable
outline of someone standing on the other side.
There’s only one way to get a better look
out at night, to get your face close to the
glass and create a shade with your hands.
And that’s exactly what I did.
I wish I hadn’t.
Because for the second time that night, I
saw that terrifying, wild pair of eyes staring
back at me.
I only looked out of the window for a slight
moment, before jumping back out of my skin
and screaming as I reached for my phone to
dial campus security.
But what I saw in that moment, literally makes
me sick to think about, but I’ll try to
recount it for the purposes of this story.
The man at the window, the sewer dwelling
man from before, didn’t have a weird haircut.
He was actually entirely bald.
But he had several different colors of hair,
superglued to his head in that one spot.
Like… like it was his collection or something,
because I also spotted an object in his right
hand: a rusty pair of scissors.
I must have screamed the poor security guy’s
ear off, before promptly hanging up, and in
an act of desperation, pushing my furniture
up to barricade the door.
*clank.
Clank.
clank.*
But it wasn’t the door I had to be worried,
about, because he started stabbing the scissors
into the window.
His taps got harder and harder.
It didn’t seem like the window would give
much longer before breaking.
I frantically searched my room for something
to fight back with, but I didn't have much.
The tapping stopped.
A bright light flooded the area, and relief
washed over as the campus security pulled
up.
I couldn’t hear or see very much through
the glare of the thick window, but from what
I could tell, the security guard asked the
guy a couple questions, which he promptly
ignored, and continued to just stare through
my window.
The guard asked him to leave, and he did comply,
but what still chills me is that he never
took his eyes off of me the entire time he
was being escorted away, until he was completely
out of sight.
The guard caught back up with me later.
I told him the whole story about the manhole.
He said I should be careful when walking home
with headphones at night.
There have been a few cases of people being
followed home by predators, and not noticing
because they were wearing headphones.
Usually it’s just some drunk weirdos going
after girls, but as we saw tonight, there
are just some weird people out there… and
you can never be too careful.
I asked him what happened with the sewer dweller
guy, and he said that, he basically just kicked
him off campus and told him he better never
see him here again.
Other than that, there wasn’t much he could
do, since the guy was on a public walkway
and didn’t really break any law.
I always make sure to get a ride home after
night classes now.
I haven’t seen the guy since then, and I
hope I never do.
--
Ahh yes.
There's nothing quite like the smooth relaxing
sounds of lo-fi when it comes to getting some
studying done.
The jazzy chords.
The bassy undertones.
The nostalgic samples.
Something about it is just so...
Enticing.
I don't even normally listen to hip-hop.
When I'm jamming out, I like my music to be
fast loud.
But when I'm trying to be productive, lyrics
and catchy riffs just distract me.
But with lo-fi, I can just melt away a whole
pile of work without even realizing it.
It's just something about the vibes; the atmosphere
created by the combination of this music with
the scenes of adorable characters doing their
thing on a rainy day or cloudy night.
Even the people in the chat of each livestream
seem to be easy going and friendly, but I
try not to get distracted by that too much.
So today I'm studying for my neurological
science exam.
We're studying the effects of pavlovian conditioning
and neurophysiology.
It's easily my favorite course.
We sometimes even do experiments to see if
we can train small rodents using the concepts
we studied.
Sometimes I'd like it if my kid brother, Tevin,
could be trained with such ease, but I seriously
doubt something like that would ever be possible
on any intelligent being, however low on the
spectrum of said intelligence he may fall.
Anddd, what do you know?
Look who's right on cue.
Tevin: "Hey bro!
Whatcha do--"
Narrator: "--STUDYING..."
Tevin: "Oh ok.
So you're bus--"
Narrator: "YES, I'm busy."
Tevin: "Oh, that's ok.
I just wanted to see if you wanted to Robo
Pizza later.
They're having a--"
Narrator: "I have an exam on Monday and I'm
already tired."
Tevin: "Well of course you're tired being
cooped up in here listening to mopey music
all day.
Narrator: "It's not mopey music--"
But before I could even finish objecting,
he, in true rodent fashion, scampered into
my room and pounced on my laptop, without
permission nor regret.
*Future funk playlist*
Narrator: "Ok, you know what Tev?
I'll take your to your dang pizza place if
you get out now and leave me alone for the
next hour!"
In the time it took him to say 'deal' he had
scattered out of my room and SLAMMED the door
behind him.
Narrator: "AND TRY NOT TO TOUCH ANYTHING ON
YOUR WAY... out..."
Well, I'd bought an hour of time to myself.
And to be totally fair, I actually didn't
mind the Future Funk playlist he had clicked
on.
It actually DID wake me up a bit.
By the end of the night I was feeling OK about
my chances on the test.
But I still had other homework to finish up.
So the following night, I found a good lo-fi
stream and..
*Music*
Time to get in the zone and knock this thing
out.
*Music and sfx*
Now this next part...
I don't fully know how to describe.
I was so in the zone doing this mindless work...
It was almost like I was asleep...
And without me really realizing it, the music
was getting more and disturbing...
Off-key...
And just downright unsettling...
(Music)
But it happened so gradually...
I almost didn't notice it until it was eating
at my anxiety.
What once relaxed me was now putting me on
a very uncomfortable edge, and for some reason...
I...
I didn't have the sense of mind to stop it.
It was like I was trapped in an unbreakable
loop of tedious work.
My body wanted to snap out of it but my mind
couldn't come up with the commands to go through
with it.
Then, for some unknown reason, I looked at
my laptop screen where the chillhop stream
was playing, and what I saw affected me so
badly, I felt like I could not even breathe.
In place of the Kawaii anime girl going her
homework, was some kind of demon.
A demon whose eyes pierced my soul so badly
I could not look away to end the suffering.
It curled it's smile in the most unimaginable
way, it almost made me sick.
It was like it was looking at me specifically,
and it was enjoying putting me under this
trance.
*Music cuts*
I don't remember what happened exactly after
that...
The next thing I knew, I was standing in my
brother's door-way, not able to remember how
or why I was there.
Tevin was staring back at me with a confused
expression.
Tevin: "Bro?
Bro!
What are you doing?"
Narrator: "I...
Uh...
How long have I been standing here?"
Tevin: "I don't know.
I was just playing the switch and I randomly
noticed you spacing out at my door.
I've been trying to wake you up for like two
whole minutes!"
I cringed at my own unawareness.
Narrator: "Uhh sorry...
I just forgot why I came in here."
Tevin: "Ok...
Are you on drugs?"
Narrator: "No!
No...
Just really tired I guess."
Not knowing what else to say, and feeling
embarrassed for myself, I headed back for
my room.
Maybe I was right.
Maybe I did just need some sleep.
The next day at school I seemed to be totally
recovered.
I KILLED the science test.
It felt like I knew every single answer.
It was overall a really good day.
The teacher had assigned a project, so after
school it seemed like it was right back to
work.
Tevin blabbered something about him wanting
me to take him somewhere as I walked in the
door but I told him I had a lot of work to.
For starters, I didn't even have a topic for
my project.
I needed ideas.
I went to go turn on some music, when I suddenly
remembered about yesterday.
The lo-fi, the demon, the randomly finding
myself in my brother's room...
I typed 🔎 Lo-fi into YouTube to see what
I could turn up and found the same stream
from yesterday.
What appeared on the screen before me seemed...
Normal...
I looked to the chat to see if there was anything
suspicious.
I don't know what I thought I'd find.
There were just some kids having a casual
conversation.
I then realized how silly it all was.
I probably just fell asleep doing my homework
and sleepwalked into by brother's room.
One of our uncles was a known sleepwalker
when he was younger, so it didn't seem so
crazy.
Before I could breathe that sigh of relief
though, something sounded kind of off about
the music.
I looked back at my screen, where the demon
from before now had it's eyes locked onto
mine.
It's cold stare petrified me.
It reached out towards me.
It felt like it was literally reaching out
of the screen, though I don't believe it actually
was possible.
For whatever reason, I didn't move.
I didn't scream.
I didn't click away to another video.
I felt like it would get me, and I would never
be back!
...
That's all I remember...
The next thing I can recollect was being in
a dark room, not knowing where I was and wondering
where it had taken me.
My eyes started to adjust, and what I saw
before me was a face; a face of horror.
It was my brother, lying in his bed terrified,
looking like he was about to scream bloody
murder.
Why was I standing over his bed?
How did I end up here?
Tevin: "W-what are you doing?"
Narrator: "I...
I don't know.
I think I've been sleepwalking."
What he told me next chilled me to the core.
Tevin: "But...
Your eyes were open.
You had the scariest look on your face."
Narrator: "I..."
Tevin: "I thought you were gonna hurt me!"
I was shocked that he would say such a thing.
I sat down on his bed.
Narrator: "Tev...
I...
You know I would never hurt you..."
Tevin: "Promise?"
Narrator: "Of course!
I would never even think about that...
I honestly don't remember anything until I
woke up right here."
Tevin: "OK..
"
He didn't sound terribly convinced, but I
told him I'd go back to bed, and asked that
he let me know if he saw me sleepwalking again.
*Door close*
It was late.
I knew it would probably be an all nighter,
as I still had a ton of homework to get done.
I also knew I'd probably have to get it done
without the assistance of any lo-fi YouTube
streams, just to play it safe.
But when I went back into my room and looked
over all the work I had left, I realized...
EVERY SINGLE ASSIGNMENT WAS DONE.
My science project was done too.
For the first time in my academic career,
I was ahead.
The next day at school was crazy.
I got my test back.
A+. 102%.
I'd nailed every question and the extra credit.
In every class, I knew every question the
teacher asked.
Sometimes I even knew what they were going
to ask before they even said anything.
Any chance that I'd be studying to any other
sound but the sound of the lo-fi stream that
night was now out the window.
When I got home I locked my door.
Hopefully that would keep me from sleepwalking
into anyone's room.
Yes, of course I was afraid that I could see
the demon again, but at this point it didn't
matter.
It was worth it.
The stream was waiting for me in my recommended.
I clicked on it, opened up a book, and started
reading.
Several minutes went by.
Nothing happened.
Possibilities started floating through my
head.
Maybe it doesn’t work if you're expecting
it.
Maybe it was a time thing.
It was earlier than I had started the previous
nights.
I cranked up the volume until it was as loud
as it would go.
No effect.
I figured my best bet was to just try studying
as normal and if it happens it--...
I heard that familiar sound.
Things were getting weird with the audio.
I looked up the screen, expecting to see the
demon staring back at me.
What I saw instead was the image of an empty
room.
It was the same room that the anime girl was
usually studying in, but it was just empty.
But as I turned back to my work...
I noticed something in the corner of my eye.
Someone was standing in MY room now, which
I quickly realized was impossible because
my door was locked.
The figure stepped forward, and what I saw…
… what I saw was a life sized version of
the demon from my computer screen, grinning
at me.
I fell back out of my chair and slammed on
the ground.
I'd never been so scared.
I tried to scramble away but somehow it was
standing over me, smiling that devilish smile.
It's mouth opened.
I can’t even properly describe it.
The mouth opening was probably wider than
a football.
All I could do was flail at it as it began
to smother me.
I could hear it's growl take over the sound
of the stream.
Darkness enveloped me as I could feel the
demon hitting me, in the chest, the arms,
the face.
The growl turned into a screech.
Tevin: "Help!!
MOM!?
DAD!?"
What I saw before me horrified and disgusted
me.
It was Tevin, on his bed again, but this time
a pair of hands were clenched tight around
his throat.
It didn't take me long to realize the horror
of the situation: that they were my hands!!
And with the lo-fi stream playing audibly
from the other room, I had no control over
myself.
I had my brother pinned down to his bed and
I was forcing the air out of him.
A flash of light filled the room as the door
slammed open.
My father quickly assessed the situation,
and I was thrown off violently.
I'd never seen him act so aggressively in
my entire life, and it felt horrible seeing
him treat me so violently.
That was a rough night.
Actually, it was the beginning of a rough
couple of months.
Luckily, my brother was ok.
The police came.
Of course, nobody believed my story.
I ended up being sent away for a while, but
with no incidents and no sign of mental illness,
thankfully my stay in the institution didn't
last long.
The next year I was back in school as normal.
I had disappeared near the end of the year,
so not too many people even noticed I was
gone.
One day in the fall, my curiosity and lack
of closure got the better of me and I muted
my computer and tried to find stream that
had supposedly set me off.
I had no intention of listening to it.
I wanted to report it.
After a search ended up giving me nothing,
I decided to look back at my browser history.
There it was.
I gulped.
Was it really a good idea to click on it after
several months with no incident?
I had to know.
*Click*
404.
The page you are trying to access does not
exist.
I was confused.
There was an important distinction.
It didn't say that the stream had been deleted
or the channel had been taken down.
According to what it said, nothing ever existed
in the first place.
I decided it wasn't worth wasting any more
of my life on.
I closed the laptop.
-2 YEARS LATER-
That was my last experience with lo-fi for
the next two years.
I made the effort to avoid it whenever I could.
I was at my first college party.
I didn't usually go to parties, but my friend
had convinced me that this one would be pretty
laid back.
I shouldn't have been surprised to hear the
sounds of lo-fi chillhop pumping through the
speakers.
I took a deep breath.
Ok.
I can handle this.
It's just music at a party.
If I need to dip outside I can.
I composed myself and walked into the party
with my friend.
*Lo-fi goes out of tune*
Thanks for listening to Al Dente Creepypasta.
Your total today comes out to $11 and 33¢
but if you like this video right now I'll
waive that fee and give you everything you
just listened to absolutely free.
Big thanks to Mr. Black’s Audio Animation
for narrating that last story.
If you’re a fan of Al Dente Creepypasta,
you’ll definitely want to subscribe to Mr.
Black’s channel by clicking here, he is
the best at telling his horror stories through
his own style of immersive sound design.
He calls it audio animation, and you definitely
need to hear it.
And as you heard in this episode, music was
a huge part of these stories.
The original score was composed by OST Maker,
and the end theme you’re hearing now is
performed by Naoya Sakamata.
Links to all these channels are available
in the credit section at the bottom of the
description.
Let me know what your favorite story was from
this episode in the comments, and remember
to subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors every
week, ring that deathbell for notifications,
and I’ll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.